non c'était à refaire je le refais 10
fois
[Musique]
le mariage et l'adoption sont désormais
ouverts au couple homosexuel
[Musique]
je me souviens de choses très fortes
évidemment je me souviens des insultes
contre les enfants des paroles
extrêmement agressives et violentes de
parlementaires contre les couples contre
les personnes homosexuelles contre les
enfants en Playmobil je me souviens de
cette violence
car dans cet acte une démarche de
fraternité parce que aucune différence
ne peut servir de prétexte à des
discriminations d'État il fait froid
dans l'hémicycle
moi je suis un oiseau équatorial
peut-être qu'un de mes souvenirs les
plus tenaces c'est que je crevette froid
toutes les nuits dans cette émission
ensuite je suis le parlementaire à guéri
donc j'ai l'habitude des batailles
parlementaires j'ai l'habitude des
séances de nuit nous proclamons par ce
texte
l'égalité
l'égalité de tous les poumons l'égalité
de toutes les familles qu'est-ce que le
mariage homosexuel va enlever au couple
hétérosexuel j'aime la vie j'aime les
gens j'aime la castagne aussi donc se
battre pour de belles causes je
considère que c'est un privilège c'est
un privilège de pouvoir porter le fer
porter des choses des arguments défendre
je savais que ce serait rude je savais
qu'à l'Assemblée ça le serait je savais
que dans les rues ça le serait pas au
code civil au prétexte de vouloir
refaire cette égalité pour tous vous
allez créer l'inégalité pour beaucoup on
n'est pas homophobe on pense juste que
ben voilà
les enfants
c'est plus clairement le homophobie ce
sont clairement des paroles homophobes
incontestablement alors en plus une
étroite test d'esprit un esprit
complètement arriéré une culture
extrêmement étroite et exiguë c'est ça
que ça révèle mais c'est
incontestablement homophobe
incontestablement il faut l'homme et la
femme le père et la mère pour engendrer
guider l'enfant sur le chemin de la vie
ça révèle une ignorance
ignorance du monde une ignorance de la
vie une ignorance de la saveur de la vie
[Musique]
pour
331 contre
225 massif
mais c'est magnifique je veux dire c'est
magnifique le président Bartolone a été
excellent dans le bout à l'autre d'un
bout à l'autre il a vraiment présidé les
débats il a tenu l'hémicycle les
parlementaires de gauche ont été
[Musique]
si vous êtes pris de désespérance
balayez tout cela ce sont des paroles
qui vont s'envoler rester avec nous et
garder la tête haute vous n'avez rien à
vous reprocher nous le disons haut et
clair à voir puissante parce que comme
disait Nietzsche les vérités tuent celle
que l'on t'est deviennent vénéneuses
merci à vous tous
[Applaudissements]
waouh j'ai un cri d'amour et une supplie
que ne cédait pas voilà c'est passé ça y
est c'est vos droits sont reconnus vos
libertés sont établies ne cédez pas au
désespoir quoi ne cédez pas ne cédez pas
aux insultes c'est mon angoisse à ce
moment-là alors que c'est une victoire
massive que j'aurais dû m'en réjouir que
j'aurais dû penser à remercier les
députés je crois qu'il le remercie quand
même parce qu'ils ont été exemplaires
mais c'est vraiment mon angoisse à ce
moment là les ados qui qui tiennent bon
et qui restent avec nous
[Musique]